I'm interested in ways to manage discomfort mild pain while waiting for a diagnosis or waiting
for treatments to alleviate pain. Okay, so what are some good natural ways to deal with pain? Well,
um, so you, uh, it's hard to answer this question because there's not really any good natural ways
to deal with pain that are going to really break the pain cycle. So you can use anti-inflammatories,
high-dose curcumin, high-dose, you know, flavonoids, which is curcumin, Boswellia, Resveratrol,
Stiny Nettle, you know, Rosemary, Cursotin, those things can help, especially for inflammatory type
pain, uh, like a headache or inflammation of the arteries, um, they can be helpful.
Stimulate the parasympathetics can also be helpful. So, uh, parasympathetic exercises, you can go
on to the membership site and look at parasympathetic exercises in sympathetic exercises to decrease
sympathetic. Those can be very helpful. What's the number one parasympathetic exercise? Coffee
animals can be real helpful for pain because they're stimulating the parasympathetics. So you're
using neurology to help decrease the pain. Um, other natural things that could help with pain is
Arnica. That could help with pain. CBD slightly could help with pain. THC, which is the, which is the,
um, psychoactive form of the marijuana can be helpful for pain. Over the years, we've had people,
you know, smoke, uh, they don't want to cigarette and help with pain. I don't know. I've never
smoked a marijuana cigarette. So I'm not the person to ask about that. But we've had people
over the years at all. I smoked marijuana back when I was in high school. That was 50 years ago.
I've never smoked sense and they smoke, you know, take a couple of puffs of a joy to it.
Really helps with pain. I can't give you any testimony to that. Um, but that's a possibility.
Some people could, you know, you could get THC and, um, in liquid form or in capsule form or in
gummy form, that could help with pain. So THC, that psychoactive form is going to give you that
psychoactive effect on your brain. And a lot of people don't like that. And I tell a story years ago
when I was in the midst of my cancer of me taking that as an attempt with my cancer. And I really did
like that. Of course, I never take any drugs or nothing. So it's just, I just don't like taking any
that sound. But I've had people that have been like purists and never put a drug in their body.
And, uh, so thankful that they tried, um, THC for their pain because it worked so well. So, um,
it is an herb. So don't feel bad about it. And it is legal. It is one every state. I think it's
a legal and every state. So, um, that's something we don't legally sell THC because you have to be a
distributor. Um, but there's, you know, in every state, there's different places you could go, uh,
and buy it and probably just whatever city. Um, so those are the things that I would think of.
Always you want to deal with the reason why the pain is there. Um, so what was there because
of a space occupied lesion, you have a mass, um, then, you know, anything you could do to help relieve,
you know, pressure on that mass is going to be helpful. Um, don't feel horrible about having to take
Tylenol or Advil or something like that. Typically Tylenol or Advil is not going to cause cancer to grow. So,
um, if, you know, there's, it can be negative effects with it, especially if you have sensitivities to
it, but, um, don't feel like you're, you know, going against the natural hypocritical,
apocratic oath by taking something like that. You have to break the pain cycle. So don't feel guilty
about that. Um, about, uh, those are the things that I would think of. Other neurological thing that
can help with mild pain is the neurological aspect of stimulating the prefrontal cortex, especially
the right prefrontal cortex. Um, overrides, there's actually, uh, Rubio, I forgot the tract name, um,
that actually, that actually blocks the parietal pain response. Can't remember the name of the tract
off the top of my head, but, but you can stimulate the right, uh, prefrontal cortex by doing novel
activities. I had a patient, I share this story. I have a patient, I, we still, I still have the
patient, I mean, she started with us about, uh, it's going to be going on 20 years ago with, uh,
rectal cancer, really bad. And she had such anal pain. We use this technique on her. And, um,
and so stimulating the right, uh, front prefrontal cortex is you, you do that by using novel activities.
That means learning something new, uh, in one of the easiest ways to do that is to start putting
together jigsaw puzzles. That's so that's what I told her to do. All she needed, she couldn't sit down,
she'd stand up and jigsaw puzzle at the table and she put it together, jigsaw puzzle. Now a jigsaw
puzzle is using your, when you are looking at jigsaw puzzle, you're stimulating your right prefrontal
cortex because it's all new, even if you've done this jigsaw puzzle five times already. So, because
all the, you got a thousand piece puzzle and you're having to find the where that goes and you're
looking for where it goes and then you have to match colors and this is an outside piece is inside
piece. Here's the church, here's the house and you're trying to put this together. It is all
right prefrontal exercise. Learning a new activity. Oh, I'm learning a new, um, song or I'm having to
be creative and write a new song or I'm having to be creative and learn how to use my computer. Those
are all right prefrontal exercises. You'll even think back, you could probably think back and have
having a time of stress or a time of pain and you had to put your mind on something new because you
had to learn something and you forgot about your pain and you may have thought, oh, because of my
mind was busy, I just forgot about it. No, you're actually stimulating that neural tract and it's
blocking the pain path. So the neuroscience is actually identified that track when you stimulate
the right prefrontal cortex, you're blocking the pain path. So and again, one of the, you know,
there you can do different crossword puzzles and different things like that, but I think jigsaw
puzzles are one of the easiest ways to do it. Um, and I always tell my brain-based patients if some
people like I hate jigsaw puzzles, I just absolutely hate to do a jigsaw puzzle. Well, if there's
an activity that you hate doing that you probably should do it, it's an indication that you really
should do that activity because that's going to build that neural pathways even more so. So those
were are would be some things you could do to help block pain pathways. And I've had people in
severe pain that that technique has worked for them.